bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 à ce
soir tout d'abord une page environnement
avec l'interview que nous a accordé jean
jouzel c'est le co prix nobel de la paix
il obtenu en 2007 avec le giec le
groupement d'études sur le climat il
viendra nous apporter son regard
d'expert sur le réchauffement climatique
nous tenterons une liaison satellite
avec le skipper versaillais tanguy de
lamotte engagé dans le vendée globe
et puis dans votre rubrique cavalaire et
auribeau bonsoir il sera question d'une
entreprise juillan courtoise qui a
trouvé son créneau c'est le moins que
l'on puisse dire seulement via le
logiciel de modélisation modelio
l'inventeur sera avec nous sur le
plateau pour en parler d'accords dont
vous n'espérez ce qu'est un logiciel de
modélisation pour ceux qui comme moi ne
le savent pas clairement et puis nous
finirons 7,8 avec un grand éclat de rire
et surtout d'humanité avec l'association
zygomatiques ses membres interviennent
au sein d'hôpitaux auprès d'enfants
malades mais tout d'abord comme tous les
soirs
ce qu'il faut retenir de l'actualité de
la journée à la grève tout d'abord des
agents du pam le service d'aidé à la
mobilité
les salariés réclament des hausses de
salaires notamment 34 sur 50
or elle cessé le travail attendons et
puis la star academy version nrj 12
c'est parti pour saison des
téléspectateurs pourront découvrir je
mens étouffe le premier prime ce sera ce
jeudi soir le lieu choisi vous l'avez vu
ses châteaux forts et cela demande une
certaine organisation comme comment une
idée somme toute logique une petite
entreprise est devenue leader sur son
marché
la belle histoire de softeam à
guyancourt grâce à un logiciel
informatique dédiée aux développeurs la
société a conquis le monde et emploie
700 salariés puis réduisons nos déchets
l'opération se déroule à elancourt des
enfants d'un centre
ont été sensibilisés au compostage le
tout de manière très ludique voilà tout
cela est à découvrir notamment dans le
7-8 et puis on la boucle tu as 20 heures
ce départ ont tout de suite avec
d'autres faits du jour
des salariés de l'entreprise lucky star
entreprises de transport adapté qui
dépend du service d aide à la mobilité
sont en grève ce mardi un reportage
signé anthony rech et patrick jacques de
dixmude spécialiste du transport de
personnes à mobilité réduite
il se retrouve à pied mais salariés de
lucky star contest les inégalités
salariales au sein de l'entreprise et
regrette la remise en cause de leur
statut de non remise en en clair ces
employés pouvaient jusqu'à présent
rentrer à leur domicile avec leur
véhicule professionnel en grève depuis
hier soir
ce mouvement a des répercussions sur les
services proposés par l'entreprise
on est à notre charge des personnes à
mobilité réduite on a conscience de la
gêne qu'on n'occasionne ça a été
l'extrême limite le fait de déclencher
une grève
ça a été pour nous vraiment une
situation va dire extrêmement
extrêmement difficile maintenant je
pense que à la direction de prendre ses
responsabilités
certains usagers se plaignent de récents
dysfonctionnements il y a quelques
semaines cette cliente n'a pas été
ramené à son domicile par son chauffeur
après son activité ce service nous coûte
pourtant près de 90 euros par mois j'ai
fou personne médailles avait commandé
assistance aux personnes endormies ps
gold phase de versailles et moi j'y vais
en regagnant voté la grève suivie par
plus de 50% des employés devraient se
prolonger pour une durée illimitée la
direction jointe par téléphone affirme
avoir fait quatre propositions dont la
mise en place d'un calendrier annuel de
négociations salariales
voilà et on va revenir dans quelques
instants avec moustapha sy daf qu'on a
entendues dans ce reportage il est
délégué syndical mais d'abord on va
démarrer par notre chiffre du jour il
s'agit de 34 c'est ce serait le nombre
d'agents qui auraient stoppé le travail
aujourd'hui alors moussa faye daf
bonsoir qu'on vous a en ligne bons soins
on va revenir d'abord sur ce mouvement
il a il est 18 heures passées est ce que
le mouvement sera ou non reconduit
demain
oui oui enfin
bonsoir oui oui mon ventre a reconduit
demain ce soir les choses avancent et
sont sur le statut de non remise en nous
nos remises en compressive bien c'est à
dire que jusqu'à présent vous aviez un
véhicule que vous pouviez utiliser pour
rentrer chez vous entre guillemets cl
c'est bien ça l'explication
et ça ne serait plus les deux
que notre travail démarré beaucoup
copiée nommé l'ombre nos demeures on ne
leur avait pas au dépôt pour récupérer
l'effectif pour aller travailler
on va y travailler directement domicile
ce cette villa a été remise en question
à partir du mois de septembre par le
recrutement de deux conducteurs à temps
partiel en rencontre rarement traité ne
sera pas très malin malheureusement oui
je vous entends bien je crois que vous
entendez pas de problème de ce côté
voilà alors je vous dise la seule
avancée c'est que la direction est prête
à quai de fait qu'on maintienne au
statut de non remise en chine on l'a
toujours rien ce plan là pour voir si la
direction par vous a fait quatre
propositions notamment de mettre en
place un accord une grille salariale en
tout cas des négociations salariales
annuelles est ce que ça vous convient ou
pas dijon peut y a rien de concret
effectivement nous a conviés à aller les
codifications règles obligatoires pour
les nao s'en prend sans pour autant lui
garantir un quelconque résultat tant au
niveau du nombre de grévistes vous
annoncez 34 grévistes sur 50 est ce que
c'est des chiffres que vous confirmez
je confirme et je m'attarde demain il y
aura également 34 rivés sur trois corps
alors quelles conséquences pour les
usagers quels conseils surtout on peut
donner à ceux qui font appel à ce
service parce que ce sont des personnes
souvent en difficulté pas des gens qui
feraient préférable qu'ils puissent
anticiper un maximum leurs déplacements
ou voir le même les retarder l'idéal
pour nous ce serait que la direction
prenne ses responsabilités bien faire on
a conscience enfin pénaliser l'ensemble
des usagers on aurait fêté agir
autrement notamment par des propositions
concrètes chose que ce soir nous n'avons
pas obtenu répète sur les 4 propositions
que la direction nous fait ce soir 3
existait déjà le des contingentements
c'est fait depuis le mois de mars
dernier seulement il ne veut pas en
contrepartie des contingentements je
suis fier pour leur forme de vos que
spectateur cdc des problématiques
effectivement qui appartiennent aux
salariés mais qui sont intéressants
aussi d'expliquer mais donc du coup au
souk
oui des heures supplémentaires les nerfs
flamande des repos compensateurs un
certain niveau
au delà de 130 heures supplémentaires
chacun supplémentaires travaillées
génère une heure de repos compensateur
afin d'éviter que les phanères que les
salariés obtiennent des repos
compensateurs
la direction a fait intervenir des
contrats à durée déterminée dans
l'entreprise est lentement aujourd'hui
de déplacer ce contingent d'heures
supplémentaires nécessaires à
l'obtention des heures cité les repos
compensateurs de 130 à 220 cette
proposition nous sommes donc ça veut
dire en gros moins de deux moins
d'argent à la fin du mois ça se résume
comme ça ça veut dire moins de repos
pour tout le travail et non les prévenus
moment d'une contrepartie contrepartie
cas d'accord est-ce que vous avez un
prochain rendez vous prévu votre
direction on a compris la grève a été
reconduite demain ce qui est un rendez
vous prévu avec votre direction
prochainement en fera sur le site donc
on va voir s'ils vont nous recevoir
d'accord d'acter merci en tout cas
moussa faye d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
et donc on a bien compris que la grève
au niveau du service pam donc plan à
l'aide à la mobilité était reconduite en
tout cas pour demain mercredi nous
allons continuer ce 7 8 avec un sujet
plus léger
voilà transition n'est pas facile